this morning's session today it's my
first time to introduce language trevor
from tdic who of course needs no
introduction and nadia's going to tell
us about applying statistical learning
theory to deep learning what we
understand what we need to understand
what we need to understand we need to
rethink but i really like
that is what's on the x-axis and as many
of you in the room like myself we all
learned a lot from that over here so
thanks so uh
i think the um
the schedule says um i think i'm going
to talk about implicit bias um i
i've spoken about implicit advice quite
a bit actually also from this stage
specifically um and
i will talk also about implicit bias but
i think
what i'm going to give is a bit more
just following up on uh
on spencer's tutorial for mysteries
so yesterday
um
spencer gave us a very nice kind of
introduction to
what i would consider the classic view
of uh statistical learning theory
and what we'll try to do now is kind of
take what spencer taught us yesterday
and see how um
how it applies or maybe doesn't apply uh
to uh um to deep learning um and in
particular we will also talk about uh
um
we will also talk about implicit bias
and we'll talk also quite a bit about
the nine over fitting that spencer
mentioned yesterday briefly so i saw
that they're going to be quite a few
talks later on uh both this afternoon
and later on this week about benign
overfitting and so um i did want to
spend some time you know getting
everybody up to speed in the tutorial
though i'm sure that
i don't know if the the people that are
speaking about benign overfitting are
happy or not happy that i'm either you
know taking away their thunder or
setting things up nicely what you should
sing as i'm sending things nicely so you
can hear about um
current work on that um
yeah
um as uh i mentioned uh
the what i the this talk also has kind
of uh
uh okay so two things you should keep in
mind so to prime you for uh uh for the
tutorial the two things you should kind
of keep in mind we'll be continuing to
think about one is how much does you
know deep learning does can
what we see in deep learning does it fit
with our classic understanding and we
can use our classroom techniques or is
it that our classic analysis techniques
the class of discipline learning like
just breaks down and we need something
completely different so like how much
can we use
um
uh tools developed over the past like
five six decades or so and i'll already
spill the beans and tell you that the
for the most part the answer is that we
can we we
you know
we didn't waste our time over the past
six decades uh the the ideas and methods
uh techniques of the build are
applicable we just have to like think
about how to apply them correctly
and the second thing is this subtitle
and this is the question uh that
whenever you want to ask a question and
or even if you don't want to ask a
question and you don't know what to ask
then
this is the question to ask like what's
on the x-axis okay so
um
we'll be looking at the it's and i think
this is important question to ask also
when you look at a paper then you see
papers and you see a plot like you know
that looks you know like
this or like this or like you know this
or like you know something else and
always you should ask okay what am i
actually seeing here what's on the
x-axis what how should i interpret this
you know the the
this x-axis is it is it the correct
x-axis or not um
the y-axis will usually be something
like error maybe that's easier uh but
the x-axis will be spending a lot of
time uh thinking about whether it's the
correct x-axis
okay so as i mentioned we'll start by uh
just very quickly uh
um uh recapping uh uh spencer's talk
from yesterday just to remind us of the
notation and get things uh uh set up to
uh how we're gonna continue talking
about him uh so uh we're gonna be you
know
again redefining supervised learning
expense already there talking about the
estimation error the approximation there
uh
measures of capacity or uniform
convergence and one thing that spencer
also mentioned maybe the main thing um
i want to get out of this is this notion
of inductive bias that from my
perspective it's kind of the central
notion in in uh
in machine learning and we'll maybe
understand a bit better what at least i
mean uh by uh by inductive bias uh we'll
then look as i mentioned how this fits
in
with the deep learning talk also about
implicit uh bias i mean
we did advertise it in the talk title so
i feel like we should talk about it but
it's also important and we will
definitely
spend quite some time talking about it
uh and as i mentioned also been night
overfitting okay uh
so feel free we have plenty of time i
think uh two and a half hours together
this morning um
and so feel free to ask me questions uh
whenever if it
don't be afraid to ask questions about
anything maybe i'll answer maybe i won't
answer but you can always ask uh if i
don't answer it maybe because they don't
know the answer or just because i'd
rather not answer right now but uh
you're not gonna know um
okay uh let's start so
um we're gonna um uh talking about the
exact same setup that uh spencer
mentioned which is supervised learning
supervised learning basically we have
some
unknown join distribution uh over in
instances or inputs x and labels y right
so you can think of it you know an image
and what's an image a character and
what's it into the character you know
whatever you want we'll be most looking
at y being just binary uh and what we
want to look is a one what we want to
get as a predictor some mapping from x
to y uh that's good on the population
and minimizes its expected loss so this
is really what we care about um
but we don't know the the joint
distribution so we don't actually know
what the expected loss of any predictor
is we want to do it based on uh uh on a
sample drawing uh that will throughout
um uh assume is drawn iad from
distribute from the population
and um aditi which i think i don't see
her here anymore though i don't
recognize anybody with the masks uh uh
yesterday um
told us about how you know this
assumption that we have samples drawn i
define population we care about actually
doesn't hold in practice and it doesn't
it never actually holds in practice but
um in this talk we'll definitely uh i
think throughout the entire talk stick
to the assumption that we have actually
samples drawn from the distribution um
right so the central objects of study is
a learning rule which is the mapping
from the training set to uh predictor
okay
um
and and so the question is the first
question you know is there a good
learning rule is there a learning rule
uh that always uh succeed succeeds in
finding a good predictor okay
and the answer is no right so this is um
and this is uh uh referred to as no free
lunch theorem which says basically no
learning rule is good right for any
learning rule you give me there exists
some reality some population
for which this learning rule is horrible
okay so okay what does this mean so of
course
you know there could be realities for
which there's no predictor that's good
right because if in reality where y is
just independent of x there's just no
predictor it's good okay so that's uh
not like uh interesting but the thing is
that there's a reality
population the source distribution right
i'm going to be using these three words
interchangeably
um for any learning rule there is a
reality for which y is just a
deterministic function of x there exists
a perfect predictor with zero loss but
your learning rule is not going to find
it
okay
so
and
more formally like you know when you say
how bad it's going to be not only is it
not going to find it but it's not going
to be doing any better than chance okay
it's not going to have error much better
than uh
than 50 like for binary classification
so there are 50 error
i can always get just by random guessing
and you're not going to do any better
than that well you can do maybe a bit
better so you can do a bit better by an
edge which is number of samples over the
um
the size of your domain um the number of
possible instances how can you do that
how can you get an edge of number of
samples over a number of possible
instances
yeah yeah so just memorizing right i
mean if you have only you know if there
are only 10 000 possible inputs 10 000
possible images in the world and you saw
a thousand of them we already saw ten
percent of them you're going to have an
edge of 10 okay so that's not really
learning but what the no free lunch
theorem tells us is you can't do any
better than that for any learning rule
there is there is a reality for which
this learning rule is not going to do
any better than memorizing okay and of
course with the size of the domain
x usually we think of it as either huge
or really in continuous or infinite
and so you can do memorizing is is
useless and you can't do any better than
chance okay so
so this is bad news in citizencon you
can't learn so how can we learn okay so
in order to learn we said so what we
said here is that there's no learning
rule uh that's good for all realities
for every learning rule right there's
some reality for which it's bad okay and
so in order to learn what we have to say
is well it's not that i don't really
care about all realities okay i don't
think that all realities are really uh
plausible okay um so i have to um
limit myself or focus or bias myself
myself onto certain realities right and
that's uh uh uh what i referred as an
inductive bias right so the inductive
bias uh we can think of it as um
uh
um in so the real device is the bias
that tells us the biases towards some
realities over others right that tells
us that our learning rule is not going
to work out for all realities is going
to learn um
uh uh
over others and we can see this um
uh um in in two different ways right so
we can either think of it as an
assumption about reality that makes our
learning role uh
um
uh uh
uh that makes a learning will work right
so uh okay sorry
uh
a bit out of it this morning okay so you
can see it sorry we can see it in two
different ways we can either see it it's
a bias that biases our algorithm so we
can see it either from an algorithmic
perspective or for analysis perspective
so you can either say
our learning rule okay
is not gonna you know i i can't
hope to it to capture all realities and
so i'm gonna bias myself towards certain
realities so in that sense the inductive
bias is a comes explicitly from the
um
is you know inductive bias comes first
and then we design our learning rule
bias biasing ourselves to certain
realities you can think of it as a kind
of roughly speaking a prior okay
although i definitely don't want to
think about it as a
uh as a prior right so it's going to
prefer certain relationship between x
and y and x and realities another thing
to another way to think about inductive
bias
is
in terms of the guarantees right so we
said that you can't get guarantees for
any uh um
[Music]
for
do you can get guarantees for any
realities so you can think of the
inductive bias is what are the
properties you know how do you you know
break the no free lunch what are the
properties of
of reality uh that you need in order to
make your uh your learning will work
like for example that you know
um
that
there exists some
hypothesis of a certain form that
explains reality well then we can say
our our learning rule is going to work
okay so maybe to make it more concrete
the most
simplest maybe type of inductive bias is
kind of this flat inductive bias and
flat inductive bias just says that some
realities are plausible and other
realities are not possible one way we're
going to even look at it is just even
look at the relationship between x so
some relationships between y and x are
plausible and some are not plausible so
we have this family of possible
relationships between y and x possible
uh predictors uh uh h uh and uh we're
only focusing on them and so the if you
think about it in terms of assumption we
say that there exists
a predictor of this form that has small
error okay okay so we're only gonna and
some referring is too flat because
inside this uh
class of possible predictors you can
think of it maybe as linear predictors
based on a certain set of features uh uh
we don't have any or we're kind of like
um
if you think of it in terms of a prior
we have a flat prior in scientists like
all of these realities that are
plausible are equally possible okay
and then um as we saw yesterday the kind
of correct learning rule to use is
empirical risk minimization to minimize
in sort of the population risk the
empirical risk and we can uh guarantee
that um this will be a good learning
rule uh by getting a uniform convergence
guarantee over all predictors in our uh
um in our class h um and
what we can get what we can get then
ensure is that if there exists a good
predictor in our class we're going to
find a predictor that's almost as good
almost by how much it's exactly the
rather market complexity i think maybe
the way that spencer defined it i'm
missing a factor of two here or maybe
not i don't remember how you defined it
okay it doesn't matter too much uh
and uh this rather macro complexity
usually scales is something like square
root of uh the capacity of the class
divided by number of samples okay so um
so what is this uh capacity of the class
um so the easiest way to think about the
capacity of the class um
for a binary uh classification the
capacity of the class is exactly the vc
dimensions we know the rather macro
complexity scale is the square root of
this dimension over a number of samples
and and what is the vc dimension why am
i calling this also capacity the vc
dimension is the the largest number of
points for which uh you can fit anything
on the
on those points you can fit like any
even random labels right so that tells
you kind of how
how many uh
uh how many data points for uh like
what's like this class how many data
points is
able to fit without any assumption right
so so this is kind of like what um you
know it tells you how much different
predictors are in this class enough to
fit like m um
endpoints and
this is
um
what this says is really there's a kind
of a dichotomy here that if you have
less than this dimension number of
points then your
um our assumption or inductive bias
doesn't tell us anything right because
on less than n points then anything is
possible and so i'm actually i don't
have any assumption at all and so
clearly i'm not going to be able to
learn with less than endpoints but what
happens is once i have more than
endpoints i can start learning right the
number um
the the number of data points you need
to learn here is proportional to this
capacity so i can you know if this
dimension is a thousand less than
thousand points i can learn more than
thousand i can start learning there's a
kind of uh um a transition okay um
and the visa dimension or the the
capacity is generally like the number of
parameters this is exact for linear
predictors uh and you know for many
classes also the number of the visa
dimension is roughly the number of
parameters we saw it um
sort of we'll we'll mention it briefly
spencer uh talked about yesterday also
for uh uh
for neural networks and there's also a
very very simple argument that the num
the vc dimension or the the capacity um
is basically always number of parameters
so
the
visa dimension is always bounded by the
low cardinality and i said it's kind of
the the size of the class right because
to to shatter uh uh end points to get
all possible behaviors and points you
need two different predictors
and if i have uh um if i can describe my
predictor using
you know a thousand bits then that means
i can have only two to the thousand
predictors so the low cardinality is
bound by a thousand right so the the low
cardinality of the class is always
bounded by the number of bits i need to
describe a predictor in the class okay
so now if i have a predictor you can
describe by you know uh 75 parameters
100 parameters okay then how many bits
do i need to describe it well i need a
hundred uh parameters times i don't know
how many bits do you guys use to
describe a real
32 i don't know 32 okay so 32 times
number of times 100 or in general and
the number of bits they have is like 32
times the number of parameters okay
and so the vc dimension is always
bounded by the number of parameters
times the number of bits you use per
parameter okay
so
um so this is kind of a very simple
argument it always tells you without
thinking at all then this image is
always bounded by the number of
frameworks that also means that whenever
somebody tells you that you know if you
um
i'm sure that uh many of you have seen
all of you i hope i guess so actually
let's uh check let's see we're on the
same page here um
how many people have seen the visa
dimension before spencer's talk
yesterday
okay good
everybody and this is the first time i
see everybody nobody's even shy to not
raise their hand okay um excellent so
you probably also saw examples when
you're shown the visa mentioned examples
of classes with a single parameter where
the visa dimension is infinite right i
mean you've all seen this okay whenever
somebody shows you such an example you
know either a
class with a single parameter of the
infant dimension vs dimension or any
type somebody says oh here's a class
with like you know uh p parameters but
it has vc dimension p squared okay in
fact spencer did that yesterday whenever
somebody shows you that they know
they're they're cheating you okay sorry
okay
because that necessarily means that you
know if the visa dimension is larger
than the number of parameters that
necessarily means that in order to
shatter you know that many points you
need to use so really a lot of bits per
uh per parameter right if i have p
parameters i'm going to shatter p
squared points i necessarily i'm going
to have to use p bits per parameter so
that means that your your your uh all
your arguments are really based on this
like super you know in this real
arithmetic or something like that and
this is like super precise uh uh
parameters and that's not really how
things you know really work okay um
and so uh yeah so so uh
um
capacity is number families but it can
also be
no number of parameters so if you have a
neural net okay so i think uh spencer
also talked about it yesterday right so
if you have a what are the parameters
for uh so we'll talk about explicit
things what are the parameters for a big
network
yeah um
it bits the weights right so it's number
of weights not the number four
okay
okay um
okay but uh so number of uh this image
is always bound in my parameters but as
uh spencer pointed out the number from
the
the capacity okay it's now or maybe not
talking exactly this dimension but the
capacity um can frequently be much much
less number of parameters okay so even
in situations where an infinite number
of parameters were
non-parametric settings we can still
bound the capacity and use like other
techniques for that uh like by bounding
the the norm or magnitude or scale of
things like in the simplest example uh
if we have linear predictors even in an
infinite dimension right so this is what
we do all the time when we use support
vector machines
where our kernel ridge regression we're
using linear predictors in infinite
dimensions but we still bound the
capacity by bounding the norm of the
predictors we know the boundary of the
capacity instead of the number of
parameters by the squared norm of the
particular square euclidean node okay
great uh so
um so what's the
game here so he said that the capacity
controls kind of uh you can think of it
as controlling this uh estimation error
term or a number of samples we need uh
to learn uh but then we have also this
uh uh term which is kind of uh uh what
is this lh starts the the best area can
get with something in the class right so
you can think of this as the
approximation error right and
this leads to the classic decomposition
of error as an approximation or an
estimation error and this is like the
main game in machine learning in one
class we want to find hypothesis classes
or assumptions about reality then on one
hand
are rich enough and large enough to
capture reality well to have a small
approximation all right so there is a
predictor in the class with small error
on the other hand to be small enough
they have small capacity and this
estimation error term is small that i
can actually learn them with a small
number of um
of samples okay um so then we can say
that like for example this uh uh model
class is good uh but this model class
maybe is not good why is this model cast
not good like based on this cartoon
the reality is very different so it's
right so so note that both these classes
they have kind of the same size if you
you know if you believe this or like of
course what i'm trying to convey this
cartoon is the size of the ellipse is
kind of the capacity both of them have
the same capacity right if you prove a
generalization bound for both of them
they'll look the same might have the
same capacity so it's not that one class
is better than the other because you can
prove better bound for it the reason one
class is better than others because it
captures reality well okay of course
they can have you know another class
that may become you know that's worse
because it's lord right so we have to
balance both of these things but this is
important thing because that means that
no matter no theorem you're going to
prove is ever going to convince me that
one hypothesis class or one learning
rule is better than another learning
because as we said every learning rule
has some reality in which it's horrible
right really convincing me that one
learning rule is better than a different
learning world you can only do
by saying something about reality you
have to say you know something about
reality you have to say that this
actually captures reality better and
that's not a mathematical statement
that's question about reality okay you
might break it up and say okay i believe
that reality behaves in this way and
this learning rule works well for you
know for this thing i believe right but
ultimately you have to make a statement
of reality
okay but this is for flight inductive
bias we usually actually don't have flat
inductive bias because usually even if
we say that for example i believe that
reality is captured well by a sparse
linear predictor okay so you know
when they say that what do i mean by
that i don't mean that reality is
captured well by a predictor with
sparsely seven or predictors sparsely 15
or particularly as far as the 50.
what i mean is that well i think that
sparse linear predictors are more likely
than less far so you know the sparser
you are you're more likely okay so
really um
what i'm defining here is some kind of
complexity measure that measures kind of
the the
the sign some
you can think of it as a complexity a
prior although i don't want you to think
about it as a as a distribution uh some
measure of you know simplicity or
complexity or how likely uh um different
predictors are again like what are you
going to be biased more towards we're
going to be biased towards things that
are simpler where this measure is
smaller okay and one argue is that
usually when you talk about uh most of
our inductive biases really are in terms
of complexity measure and not in terms
of this flat hypothesis class right so
we talked about
sparsely or maybe if you uh are
you know
in high school when you fit you know in
fit uh you get some points and you try
to fit a
polynomial through them then you kind of
you know prefer the lower degree
polynomial but you didn't know in
advance what the degree is right you
have a bias towards lower degree so you
think in this case the complexity is
like the degree of the polynomial
even if you're just using linear
predictions you don't actually know
which features you're going to have so
maybe you have some kind of uh
complexity that you know having less
features or simpler features um and all
these examples are discrete right so you
know when we think of this discrete
complexity measure like sparsity or
degree or polynomial you can also talk
about you know continuous complexity
measures like the norm right so if
you're using we mentioned support vector
machines before then there we're using
linear predictors over an infinite
feature space our feature space is this
may be fixed right we fix the kernel um
but then we're saying oh we prefer low
norm predictors but what norm we don't
say in advance that we want predictors
in number 37.653
right we just say that i pref i would be
more biased i would prefer a predictor
with number 37.693 over a particular
known 56.4 right so if i have you know
if i have to choose between those two
predictors right i'm going to choose the
smaller one right
okay
and so i i just i intentionally want to
emphasize here first the discrete ones
because somehow we we frequently
associate uh uh when you're talking
about discrete control like you know
dimensionality or rank or something we
think of the fixed hypothesis class when
we think about continuous control we
think of it in terms of complexity
measure but these things are completely
orthogonal right you can have a you know
continuous or discrete
and then have either a
flat hypothesis class or this complexity
measure okay is this uh clear
okay so how do we learn if we have uh
uh with inductive bias it's given by a
complexity measure so now what we want
to do is actually minimize two things
right we still want to minimize the
empirical error but
okay there's a typo here can somebody
spot the typo
i intentionally put the typo
somebody spot the type okay so what you
minimize is not the
um we can minimize this is uh our
population error which we kind of
minimize there's a half missing here
we're of course going to minimize the
empirical error okay uh so you want a
predictor um
with the
that
both have small empirical error but we
also want to bias yourself to its uh
simple predictors right so you want to
predict that both has small empirical
error and small complexity okay as uh
simple okay uh so what do i mean by that
i mean there are two objectives here and
those objectives might be competing with
each other right so this is and they
generally are competing because you know
usually the simplest possible predictor
is going to have like what if i look at
for example degree what's the simplest
possible predictor
sorry
oh even simpler than that
constant right degree zero polynomial
but that's probably going to have
horrible error i mean that's going to
have you know uh
you know that's that's going to be a
pretty bad predictor okay um so the
simplest possible predictor is or you
know if you look at norm right what's
the simplest possible predictor if i
think you know think about svms or uh
your current regression or your in
general like low norm prediction what's
the simplest possible predictive my
complexity measure is the norm of linear
predictor
zero right the zero predictor okay the
zero predictor is you know it's going to
always have you know null error right
definition right and i'm not going to
get anywhere right and and so i always
kind of have a
a tension between them and so the way to
think about this is a biker optimization
problem right so i have these two um
these two competing objectives and here
i actually did write it correctly the
empirical error on one hand and the
complexity on the other hand and one i
want to find is a predictor that's like
as close as possible to here right that
has small empirical error and uh small
complexity okay
but that's generally not possible okay
so i have to compromise so the way uh to
think about this plot is like any
possible predictor i plotted the
dot here for you know it's a combination
of empirical error and uh in complexity
and this uh yellow
or whatever color this is are the
attain possible attainable values okay
so the thing is that i'm definitely not
going to want this predictor why will i
not want this predictor
see there's some predictor that you know
this particular predictor that has you
know this empirical error in this
complexity why would i not want this
predictor yeah so i can do better i can
for example with the same complexity i
can get smaller error right or with the
same uh or if i know why do i want this
particular right because i can get
either small error with the same error i
can find a similar predictor that has
the same error right so i'm definitely
not going to want any one on the you
know inside here the only predictors i
might want to consider are predictors
over here okay what's this so this is
i think of it as the pareto frontier uh
is the the predictors that are you know
kind of i cannot any predictor here this
predictor maybe i'm going to want it
because you know i can't find a simpler
predictor that has better error right if
i want something which i can find
something with maybe smaller air but
then it's going to be more complex so
now it depends how i balance complexity
and error okay and what is this path um
so this is the the pareto frontier the
way we think about in in machine
learning is usually the realization path
right so as i what's the realization
path so one way to think about balancing
the empirical error and the
complexity
is by minimizing some kind of linear
combination of them the
and again i'm i'm really apologize for
missing
uh either a hat or an s here i mean
these are all empirical errors okay
this is particularly embarrassing
because i already use these slides quite
a bit and probably the next time i'm
gonna use them i'm gonna gonna forget to
correct it if somebody can remind me
afterwards send me email to correct it i
appreciate it
and um and so you know some linear
combination and as we vary lambda right
that's the trade-off between the
empirical error and the
uh and the complexity right so when uh
lambda is very very high i really want
something with small complexity okay uh
and so even the expense of getting very
high errors i'm going to be somewhere
over here and there's a lower lambda i'm
saying okay i'm willing to compromise on
complexity in order to get something
with smaller error until lambda goes to
zero and i'm over here okay
um you know i don't really care about
lambda usually when they go into this
they don't have some like you know
alumni in the same way that i don't know
i want a predictor with number 36.7 i
also don't know that i want to use
lambda 0.0734 okay so really lambda for
me is just some nuisance really what i
care about is this object which is the
pareto frontier the organization path
and lambda this formulation with lambda
is just some way of uh
of exploring uh on getting all the
predictors in this path they can do it
and also in other ways for example i can
minimize the error subject to constraint
in the complexity or minimize the
complexity subject constraint an error
or they always do any other you know
monotone combinations of them and vary
the balance the point is they get like
essentially what they get is the set of
all these predictors and the way we
actually select between these predictors
is not by coming up with some lambda but
you know by using some kind of
validation
question yeah i guess i'm curious like
why we just how we justify like the
complexity measure as an inductive bias
like why would we want
the simplest possible predictor okay so
um
the way i think about it is the other
way around you have to have an inductive
bias you're going to have some inductive
bias i'm going to call your inductive
bias the complexity
so the fact that i use the word
complexity i think somebody yesterday i
think was
still here okay so matus yesterday said
uh that he doesn't know what simple
means right that okay i don't know what
simple means either symbol can mean a
bunch of different things so this
complexity measure is not some universal
definition there's no in fact i don't
think there's a universal definition of
what simple means and what complex means
okay uh well
actually maybe there is but that's a
different question
theoretical sense maybe and a synthetic
theoretical sense but there's no
universal definition of what simple
means in complexity okay but rather in
order to do learning you have to decide
what single means and what complex means
okay because we said that in order to do
learning you have to have inductive bias
you cannot do learning without deductive
bias
and that means that you're going to buy
us towards some things over other things
and i'm going to call the things you're
going to buy is too simple just the name
i'm going to call them and the things
you're going to bite away from complex
so if you're going to use uh uh if your
predictor is going to be if your
learning rule is going to be a
minimizing the norm of the predictor i'm
going to say that you're going to use a
complexity measure which is the norm
okay
say which one that the including node
right okay if your predictor is going to
be trying to get this far solution i'm
going to call your complexity measure uh
i'm going to say that supports use your
complex dimension
does that
make sense yes
i'm curious like what are what would be
an inductive bias a complexity measure
that doesn't look like like because
these i feel like you could squint at
all these things and be like well degree
of the polynomial oh yeah okay so the
thing is that um
that
it's not surprising because generally we
believe that simpler things you know we
use okay so it goes back towards the
word simple mean and i agree with matuch
i don't know what simple means right but
we kind of have this feeling and this is
uh uh formulated uh by uh uh
we should always prefer simpler things
but a simpler mean i don't know okay so
we have many different ways of saying
what similar mean but it's not
surprising
that whatever you know we feel is a good
inductive bias
we associate it with being simple and
i'd argue that actually the way it works
the other way around that in your brain
when the reason you see all these things
is simple is because you think of the
good inductive biases you know okay
it's simple okay
um
but
i i
i don't know i can come up with a whole
list of uh other things here like for
example uh i can
uh you know i can write uh expressions
or anything i can write expressions look
very scary to you or look scary to me at
least all kinds of you know they define
all kinds of uh
properties of functions that
in some sense mean that they're simple
in some way i know but maybe because
they're not familiar to you they're not
going to immediately look jump out as
simple okay now these things
intentionally put your things that you
are going to be
the reason i put here these examples is
because i think the simplest examples of
simplicity right
um
but uh
but yeah i mean this is it really boils
down to what you see before is what is a
good inductive advice what makes
something a good inductiveness and i
think it is something that's a good
in-depth advice it's really
it's uh
it corresponds you know reality it
corresponds well to reality
but i mean i'm going around in circles
because i think i as much of said
yesterday i don't think there's an
answer to this question
um
okay so
um
right okay and then um so i'm going to
refer to this rule as the spot for this
minimization why structures minimization
this is a term that uh vapnek introduced
because in some sense instead of just
minimizing the empirical risk uh we're
minimizing both the
empirical risks approximation error
which is empirical risk and in some
sense the estimation error which is the
uh the population risk and how can we
analyze this so roughly speaking we can
now guarantee and we can have a similar
guarantee and the guarantee involves
also
um uh you know you said that if there
exists a particular h star that's both
uh simple you know according this
measure so low complexity and a small
error i can compete with this predictor
and what's my estimation error term
going to be so it's going to involve
the capacity of this sublevel set of the
complexity measure including it right so
so what's going on here so
the thing is that a lot of our study of
uh
of physical learning theory like what
spencer mentioned yesterday
appears to be about flat inductive bias
right we talk about uniform convergence
of a fixed class is it really because we
use flat inductive bias no we're not
going to use flat inductive bias but the
thing is that when we use non-flat
inductive device when we use a
complexity measure we can also think of
this complexity measure equivalently is
defining
this hierarchy of hypothesis classes
what is this hierarchy it's just the
sub-level sets of the complexity measure
right so each each set here there's they
just do three of them but there's a
continuous if the complexity measures
continuous there's a continuum of them
are just the sub-level sets of our
complexity measure okay and then in
order to say you know how well we're
going to learn or how well we're going
to compete with some predictor h star we
have to find the sub-level set
of
why did i okay
um maybe i'll
draw it here okay
if there exists a predictor that we
think is simple it has small complexity
and small error then to say how well
we're going to compete with it we're
going to have to find the sub-level set
off the complexity measure that includes
it right so it might look like this this
is this sub-level set right so these are
you know other sub-level sets of the
complexity measure right
we find the sub-level set that includes
it and now we have to ask what is the
capacity of this sublevel set
okay and that's the
um
the term that's uh that's here right and
that's going to determine how many
samples we need to and we need in order
to compete with this predictor
okay
so our
the learning theory you know all our
results for single hypothesis classes
for flat inductive bias
are we can apply them also when we have
this hierarchy of
hypothesis classes or a complexity
measure now
two things here i want to point out and
and this is the terminology at least i'm
using here i mean maybe other people use
slightly different terminology
i distinguish between complexity measure
and capacity okay so the complexity
measure is an arbitrary measure it
doesn't have to be you know you it's
just what you think captures reality let
me say we had you know degrees sparsity
norm you can come up with any norm is a
valid complexity measure in fact any
any function the complexity measure is
any function uh from uh the predictors
to zero to you know to the reals
positive fields it doesn't really matter
okay because
you know if i think the complexity
measures so the thing is that the actual
numeric value of the complexity measure
is completely irrelevant what really
matters is only how it orders different
predictors how it says that one
predictor is simply another so any
monotone transformation is fine so
i think that i'm going to use the
complexity measure which is uh the
euclidean norm and prager
is actually going to use the squared
euclidean norm it doesn't matter we're
using the same complexity measure right
they're just different by simultaneous
the reason that we're using the same
complexity measure is that the you know
we're going to have exact same hierarchy
of
offsets okay
so um so the complexity measure can be
anything and the numerical value of the
complexity measure is completely
meaningless right so if somebody comes
up uh with and this is you know
something new if somebody comes up with
some uh
norm that they say is a very good
measure and then they measure and say
look i measured in reality is well
captured by a predictor with norm
536.7
what does that tell you tells you
absolutely nothing right if they just
divide that that norm is the norm
divided by seven you'll get a different
number but it's exactly the same you
know method exactly same learning rule
the
the capacity is a meaningful quantity
okay the capacity tells you really what
is the size of a sub-level set in this
hierarchy right how many random examples
can it fit okay
so if you think of some and note that
you can think of this function which is
the capacity of a sub-level set at a
certain uh level okay that's a way of
taking so uh of
putting meaning into a
into a complex measure so coming forth
so say sam uh came up with some norm and
said this norm is great and then he
measured this neural net when he says
this really captures because it's neural
net has a norm of 536.7 it doesn't tell
me anything but now if i actually know
how to calculate the capacity of the
sub-levels the capacity of the sub-level
sets of his norm and i calculated that
and i found that the capacity is you
know fifteen thousand that number
fifteen thousand is meaningful because i
need i know that in order to learn that
reality to learn a predictor that's you
know
as good as that uh
uh predictor that he has that has
whatever norm i said i need
you know more than fifteen thousand
maybe a bit more than fifteen thousand
examples and that number now becomes
meaningful okay so also in particular um
this is where uh our you know work and
learning theory comes in and calculating
capacity the complexity measure anybody
can come up with okay and you don't need
also know that for the learning rule you
don't need to actually you know be able
to calculate this generalization the the
capacity measure which is generalization
bound right you only need to calculate
the generalization but not in order to
actually use the complexity measure but
only to understand it
okay so now that means that we're that's
uh okay but let's go back to here so he
said that
before oh wow i'm going slow okay let me
try to speed up a bit so um
we said before that our game was coming
up with a with complexity uh with sorry
with hypothesis class does it capture
reality uh well or not too big but now
really our game is you know i'm going to
come up with the hypothesis guys so
we're going to come up with hierarchical
hypothesis classes or complexity
measures right so we have these uh two
uh uh
complexity measures each one represented
by a hierarchy and now i can say that
one of them is better than the other
which one is better which one is better
the blue one or the black
one the black one right because the
black one is going to capture reality
with the smaller class right the blue
one eventually is going to capture
reality but with a much larger class
right you can come up with something
like this and then say okay is this one
better or worse so again i mean depends
on how you know how close is going to
get reality and how big is it going to
be when it gets uh to reality okay good
so this is uh so far we didn't talk
about deep learning this is just classic
uh learning theory now let's see how it
applies uh to deep learning so what is
deep learning i mean deep learning is
just
learning using a particular
hypothesis class a particular family of
hypothesis classes particularly
inductive bias which is that reality can
be captured by
feed forward uh on neural network okay
or at least in this talk we'll focus
about feed for neural networks when we
uh heard
that we hear uh talks no we didn't but i
think we'll still we'll hear talks about
the models that go beyond uh
feed for neural networks uh right and
feed forward neural networks are okay so
what do we mean that there's a
hypothesis class we have to think of it
as a hypothesis class so there's you
know what we we usually think about is
we fix the architecture so we fix the
the graph okay and the activation
function um and then we learn the
weights right so the hypothesis class
here all the functions we you know the
use made the inductive devices they have
an architecture i'm saying our function
represented using this architecture with
some setting of the weights okay so just
a bit of the historical perspective now
we associate fit4 networks uh or deep
you know we associate our networks very
strongly with learning right so if
somebody tells you that they work on
neural nets you kind of assume that they
actually work on on machine learning
this was actually not uh
uh not the historical uh development
okay so um
anybody know where the when this model
for feed and feed forward neural
networks developed
90s the 80s the 50s
i hear 50s something anybody uh
better uh
okay so actually in the 40s and 43 okay
so it's developed by 1943 uh by mccomb
and pitts um so
i i really like uh the stories of walter
pitts uh he was uh
he was a middle school dropout okay
so he grew up in a rough neighborhood in
detroit uh his family would give him a
hard time because he would go to the
library and read books
and that was completely unacceptable
he actually uh at some point he read uh
um
he read russell's principle mathematica
and he had some uh comments about it so
he he wrote russell in berkeley as in
say in cambridge uh russell was
definitely done in berkeley he wrote uh
uh russell with comments about that this
is when he was actually 12 or something
like that
he
uh wrote russell with comments about
principal mathematica and his response
russell invited him to come to cambridge
and study there he never actually made
it to cambridge but when russell was
visiting the university of chicago so
chicago is a bit closer to detroit and
he ran away from home um at age
12 and at age 15 he ran away from home
to meet stuart russell university of
chicago and he stayed university of
chicago and then he just hung around
university of chicago he never enrolled
he just like kind of hung around there
uh slept in the quarters he's uh
homeless uh went to classes occasionally
popped into people's offices with uh you
know clever comments um
and then uh in uh when he was 17 and
still kind of wandering the halls of
university of chicago then warren uh
mccullough who was a more uh respectable
person he was a
professor of
uh psychology and medicine actually in
not in new chicago but in uic university
in chicago which was where the medical
school was at the time um and he kind of
found him and adopted him he came to
live with him uh and they worked
together and and uh
mccollum was interested in neuroscience
and he got
pits also interested in that
and they were really interested in the
brain and how could the brain do stuff
like how could the brain compute okay
what would cola now compute
and they uh wanted to come up with a
a model that is you know maybe inspired
by their brain but they are definitely
not trying they were fully aware that
they're not actually doing neuroscience
that they're doing computation they're
thinking of in general about how can we
compute that was the question they asked
so this is uh the early 40s
shannon and uh
turing have just
very recently in the past like three
four years uh published their work
touring on with both of them
um so this is shannon's master thesis
and
turing's paper about universal
computation both of them basically ends
asking you how can we compute right and
suggesting people at the time were
asking about you know how can we model
this phenomena of computation okay so so
turing
modeled it with this turing machine in
shannon which is probably the most
influential by far the most influential
of these three uh uh model computation
uh using logical gates right so this was
shannon's master thesis this now we take
it for granted if you want to compute
something you can use you know you can
use boolean algebra representing since
we can build once you construct logical
gates you can compute anything using uh
boolean algebra right
and so shannon had this model of
computational logical gates touring
using the turing machine
and they they
thought of can we have a simpler model
uh for computation and their model for
computation was the feedforward neural
net exactly as we're presenting it uh uh
here the only maybe slight difference is
we were talking about a general
activation and they looked specifically
just threshold activations okay so but
other than that nothing changed since
1943 in terms of the model this is feed
for neural networks as you can see now
in any textbook or any course is exactly
mccollum and
pitts model
but their interest was not in learning
it was in computation they said that
look using this model if we connect
things in particular way and set the
weights in a particular way we can
compute any function so the result
similar mirroring shannon's result with
logical gates they said you can do that
also with the with these threshold uh
threshold units which are more maybe
simpler and and uh and plausible
and
they were not at all talking about
learning the weights okay so that came
up much later um as late as 1950s then
neural nets were still studied uh uh as
a as a model of computation so marvin
minsky who is not a fan of learning at
all right so marvin minsky uh really
does not believe in did not believe he's
not with us anymore in learning but
rather in like kind of hard-coded uh
ai
marvin minsky's i don't think i'm not
sure if it's actually his phd thesis but
it's work he did while while he was in
princeton he actually implemented uh
in uh the mccollum pitts neuron right so
to electronically implement it so they
their work was completely theoretical um
actually implemented it and build it and
with the point of showing actually how
you can he built a computer using a
neural net compute things he had like
about uh i think order of 50 to 100 of
these neurons you can still see some
pictures of them and to actually show
you can build a computer uh uh using
this and remember the time we're still
trying to figure out how to compute like
the the computers we have now the von
neumann architecture was still kind of
it already existed that only started to
exist at the time the early 50s by the
late 50s um
minsky lost interest in neural networks
because he he realized that von neumann
architectures are much more powerful
than neural networks as computers and so
there's no point in neural networks um
and so that was kind of maybe the end of
neural networks as a method of computing
and of course later on we realized them
as a method for uh we were now using
them for learning right and the main
difference here is whether we hardcore
the weights or whether we learn the
weights based on data okay okay so um
with that said about uh uh
uh yeah i think it's it's an important
well i i don't the fact that i like this
historical story about uh um
pits and the calm then i think it's
important to keep in mind that the the
neural nets on you that are now so
strongly associated with the with
learning right and learning is is not
you know they were not initially uh
developed for learning anyway if i think
if we think of it in terms of learning
then we have this hypothesis class we
said that hypothesis class you know this
inductive bias or hypothesis class which
is you know all the functions have been
presented by a fixed architecture with
different weights and the weights and we
know that the questions we have to ask
about it are these two questions you
know
what is the capacity what's the capacity
if this uh class this is going to tell
us the
same complexity and uh what's the
expressive power how how well can it
capture our approximate reality and
yesterday uh um
spencer talked to us about the capacity
of neural networks and a bunch of
results and then maybe the simplest
result is if i have a
neural network with uh
um
uh uh some number of edges and and soon
depth then i can uh uh
with at least with real activations uh
the capacity is number of parameters
times the depth this is withdrawal
activations if i actually
have threshold activations then this
depth dependence goes away and as we
said also if uh you limit the number of
bits per uh
per weight and also this you know for
very simple reasons the depth uh
dependence goes away and we can you know
understand the capacity just in terms of
the number of parameters okay so this is
at least one way of bounding capacity um
and so you know have good answers and
these are results that started actually
the most recent are are from the past
few years but started already and
appearing in the 90s and now the second
thing we have to talk about is the
expressive power how well can neural
networks capture around maybe this is
the more interesting question so what
can we express with neural networks um
so
a bunch of stuff so first of all if we
think about a general uh computation
well we can express uh end gates right
so if you have uh
uh
if you have a unit with a high threshold
then for it to be active kind of you
have you need all the inputs to be
active so you can express an end gate it
can cast an or gate right if you have a
unit with a
small with a low uh threshold
and
interestingly and this was maybe uh
one of the the the
um
interesting things but neural network
was unknown linear predictors it can
express end gates and or gates neural
networks you know for example can also
express parities xor gates and we also
talked about it somebody talked about it
yesterday right there was a talk about
it yesterday right um
right um and i think we'll hear some
more talks about uh learning parities
and maybe this is one is there's
something difficult to express with the
linear networks we can definitely
express it with the
neural nets
the thing is once we can express n gates
and or gates uh and we can also express
negation just by having negative weights
then we can actually express any
function okay how can you express any
function well in particular where we can
express any function we can build a
circuit okay so let's talk a bit about
learning circuits versus neural nets so
we talked about the hypothesis class of
neural nets you can also talk about the
hypothesis class of circuits okay so
what's hypothesis class of circuits uh
this hypothesis has defined by actually
two complex to measure the depth of the
circuit and size of the circuit okay the
number of gates in the longest path from
input to output and it's all the
functions you know from you know talking
let's talk just about binary inputs and
binary output all the functions
uh that can be implemented by a circuit
with like i know and or not gates uh
with the
size with the size many gates and uh
longest pathway into dealt with size
depth okay so this is a valid hypothesis
class
and again thanks to
shannon's master thesis we know that we
can implement any function with a large
enough
circuit
but
how do we relate learning circuits to
learning neural nets right so know that
when we learn a neural net we say the
architecture is fixed and we learn the
weights
and here when you talk about learning
circuits there's no weights and what
we're learning is the architecture we're
learning the interconnect between the
the gates okay but still i claim
that if um i can learn neural nets i can
also learn circuits so in other words i
can embed the cloud this class of
circuits of certain depth and certain
size in the class of uh
in the hypothesis class of neural
networks with a fixed architecture how
can i do that
right so okay i need to choose a single
architecture for my class of neural nets
is characterized by architecture right
so you have to choose a single
architecture and with that architecture
i claim that just by
sending different weights i can
implement any circuit
how can i do that
yeah
do you have an architecture
that includes all the different possible
circuit embeddings and then like have
weights connected to them that are one
or zero depending on which one right so
what i'll do is
daniel what daniel suggested so i have
an architect what is this architecture
includes all possible connections i have
a name for that architecture
fully connected architecture so i'm
going to have a fully connected
architecture and now i'm going to choose
which you know each
neuron is going to end up corresponding
to a gate and the way i'm going to
choose what's going to be connected to
that gate is i'm going to choose which
weights going into it are going to be
one and the rest are going to be zero
and i also maybe choose you know which
gate it's going to be by each setting
the the activation or maybe not gates by
by negating right
so um
so you can choose i can set the
architecture by setting the weights
right what we're doing here is basically
uh uh it's like programming in fpga
right so you're familiar with the fpgas
field programmable gate arrays they're
exactly that it's a chip that includes
you get to choose your circuit how do
you get to choose your circuit you have
a fully connected kind of like circuit
and you choose which wires to actually
include in which wires to you know which
wires to bring in and which not to burn
in and also get to set the gates okay
good so that means that this hypothesis
class of neural networks is as powerful
as a hypothesis class of circuits which
means it can represent any function so
that's great that has great expressive
power this is for uh uh
this was for binary inputs like plus
minus one inputs but we can get also
similar results that tell us we can
capture anything or at least approximate
anything also for continuous uh uh
uh also for continuous inputs so there's
a whole bunch of
results approximation theory these
reversal representation results to tell
us that any function or any okay now
depend any function can be approximately
uh
by uh by a neural network okay so now to
make this concrete i have to tell you
exactly what i mean by any like can be
continuous and smooth and it's something
that's very continuous even any
measurable function and what i mean by
approximated
but roughly speaking again i can capture
any function using a neuron
so what's the problem with these results
so several results it tells us both for
discrete and continuous functions any
function can be captured by a neuron so
that's great because it's you know it
seems that neural nets are actually have
amazing expressive power we said we have
to worry about two things right the uh
capacity and expressive power and
expressive power is
anything i can capture anything so
what's wrong with these results
right
right so the thing is like it's true
that it can capture anything but using
huge networks right so it's true that
any function can be approximately the
circuit but this circuit is going to be
huge which is going to correspond to a
network that's going to be huge okay how
large i mean the size of the circuit is
going to be uh you know uh something
like you know
where it's number parameters is going to
be even more than two to the d so d
times so the d if i have d inputs okay
and similarly for the
uh universal approximation results we
have a size that explodes exponentially
with the dimensionality okay
and this of course defies the point
because what we wanted is to be able to
have hypothesis classes can capture
reality well using small capacity and
here it's huge capacity it's exponential
capacity it's completely useless you
know we might as well memory you know at
this point if we need more than two to
these samples we might as well memorize
we only have a domain of size two to the
d
so really the the more interesting
question is what can small neural
networks represent okay
okay so now we can think of what it can
represent and we can think about you
know first of all kind of theo geometric
things like here we can have uh unjust
one layer net a single hand layer
network represent intersections of half
spaces and if we have like another layer
we can have uh you know uses of
intersections that have spaces and you
can kind of play with this on and on but
really
maybe the more uh most uh uh interesting
thing to say is that neural networks can
really represent um we can have this
hierarchy where successive layers
represent more and more and more complex
features right in the same way they kind
of have in this diagram we have you know
we progressively build more and more uh
complex things
and this is maybe if you go to a
actually are there i know probably
mostly are there any vision researchers
here that work in computer vision and
then willing to admit it
nobody okay so um
i'm sure there are you just are too shy
so if you go to a computer vision
researcher especially but you know also
others and asking why neural networks
good and say they'll answer really about
this expressive power right and they say
neural networks are good because they
can really capture this visual phenomena
many phenomena well because that it says
it's hierarchy then the lower levels i
have this very
simple features like these low-level
features maybe edges and then um using
them i can then construct an
intermediate units represent some kind
of intermediate maybe geometric features
and then uh
higher up i have these uh higher level
almost semantic feature like you know a
bird or a wheel or a sun i don't know
what i have here right and using these
things i can really uh um that means
that they really you know uh uh um can
capture uh reality is you know does have
this article structure and so it can
they can capture reality well okay okay
so maybe this is the most uh convincing
reason um
um uh
to say that your reality really can be
captured well by small uh neural next
good so this is maybe the the the view
that we had uh
uh so far at least from the first half
of uh spencer's talk uh spencer's
tutorial that we can say neural networks
are great because we can we understand
their capacity okay the capacity just
corresponds you know can be bounded by
the number by the size of the network
and using fairly small networks we can
actually capture reality very well so
that's great okay
but in fact what i would say i'm not a
vision researcher okay um i have a much
better reason to say that neural
networks are a very good expressive
power so i said that neural networks can
capture anything
uh but using huge networks but i can i
claim that even using small networks i
can capture anything and why is that so
the thing is that any function
computable in time t can be represented
by a neural net of size t
poly log t okay so size almost uh size
linear in the time and i claim that
really the only thing i care about are
functions that can be computed
efficiently so this is not learned
efficiently this is computed efficiently
so to understand that i want to take a
step back i'm going to you know what is
machine learning so my view of machine
learning
um machine learning is an engineering
paradigm it's an engineering paradigm of
being lazy okay so there are people here
that are you know uh maybe not lazy and
are really good programmers okay um so
if there's uh somebody who's a uh and
but and that's you know not the machine
learning approach the non-machining
approach is to sit down and write a
program that does something right so you
want to do you know an ocr system
you know exactly how the letters you
know character recognition you know
exactly how all the letters felt like
enough but look like all of you do you
can all go and all of you know how to
program i hope you can all go and sit
down and program a character recognition
system right so c
find you know check if it has you know
two diagonal lines within a certain
angle and horizontal line between them
and that call that an a and if it's you
know so forth right you can all do that
but i i i wouldn't envy you right that
would be a lot of work right the machine
learning approach is to say don't work
so hard just collect a bunch of examples
of a's a bunch of examples of b's and
bunch of examples in c crank competitive
machine learning system and pop out the
predictor okay but the thing is that
since my point my my uh goal is just to
compete with the you know with
programming eliminate the programming
then if the programmer can do it then i
don't need to you know there's no but no
point in doing it also i'm going to
learn something and then i want to be
able to get a predictor and then i want
to put your predictor in your phone
right so the predictor better actually
be implementable and be able to work
reasonably fast right
and so
um
so the only thing i want to care about
is programs that actually run reasonably
in reasonable amount of time
and so in some sense this hypothesis
class the class of all predictors that
are you know efficient
is the the only thing i care about i
don't care about learning some if
there's a reality for which there's no
efficient predictor i just don't care
about learning it at all okay so this in
my perspective is a class of all
functions all functions are actually
computable efficiently okay
and
and the thing is that if we said before
and what we saw is that neural networks
can actually learn this class
okay so note that
when we started by saying there's no
free lunch right so there's there's no
learning rule that can learn anything
but now i'm telling you that there is a
learning rule that can learn anything
right neural nets can learn anything
because this is anything right in some
sense so what's going on here so really
we have to
maybe think again about the snow lunch
theorem and it turns out that there is a
free lunch not not this week but you
know and uh here there is uh here you're
on you're on your own for lunch
sorry
how the simons works but um you get free
breakfast but um but there is a free
lunch because actually
um this class of uh
functions can computed and time t can
actually be learned with a really fairly
reasonable number of uh samples only
number of samples corresponds to the
runtime and in order to see this much
more directly let's even look at a more
generous class
rather than programs that
run in time t let's look at the class of
all the functions can for which there's
a program
of length t
okay so you know that's you know any
program that you can be on the runtime
for program but it's length i mean at
least my model i always like read the
you know load the program to start with
so you know the runtime is always
bounded by the
uh the length of the program is always
bounded by one time so this is a much
much bigger class
in this class clearly i can learn in
time t because again if i just look at
the cardinality of the class we said
that or the number of bits we said that
the capacity of the class is bounded by
a number of bits needed to represent it
and if a program is a length t that
means it can present it by t times i
know 8 7 unicode 16 i don't know let's
stick with seven okay by 70 bits okay
and so that means that its capacity is
only only 70 or order of t okay so we
can see that we can easily uh
learn it with number of samples it's
only as long as the length of the
program which is really not much if you
think about it that means that you know
yes you know
if there exists some predictor with i
don't know like you know
four million characters that's a pretty
generous program and program with a you
know four megabyte uh uh
program
um then you can learn that with only a
few million examples i mean that's
really nothing in the scale we have
married so this is
a really strong result so so what's the
problem of this why
why don't we actually use these
inductive biases why don't this is the
i mean this bias of you know short
programs or fast programs is
absolutely the best inductive bias to
learn like it can beat you know if you
can actually learn the the program you
know uh uh you know do a little
structurous minimization for error and
you know run time with the program
that's going to be
i assure you that's going to be anything
you have okay any other learning rule so
why don't we use this what's the problem
with this
why don't we actually learn by finding a
short program with small error or a
program with small run time and small
error
anybody actually tried this
you want to try it now
why not
yeah so solving this erm problem or
structural synonymization problem is
very difficult right so optimizing over
the space of all programs is very hard
okay um it's in fact
not only is it very hard it's impossible
right so finding
uh the
uh shortest pro fight you know
optimizing over all short
finding the
shortest program that has small error is
actually or
it's actually not even computed or even
finding you know what's the best program
at the certain likelihood it's not
computable because we're programming
just checking if it has error if it has
smaller or not it's not not computed
so this is not only hard let's say just
outright impossible
uh okay we can make it a bit we can make
it computable but at least if we stick
to uh uh instead of short programs we
stick really what we care about which is
small
we are a bit careful with how we define
things then we can actually make it uh
computable uh but then uh it's not too
difficult to show that uh erm for
programs that run in time t so if asking
what's the smallest area you can get
with a program that runs in time with
most teams maybe this is a well-defined
problem it is computable um it's
np-complete okay so is that good news or
bad news telling you that it's
np-complete
who thinks it's who thinks it's bad news
only one you know you guys are really
not afraid who thinks it's good news
why is it good news
i'd be out of a job
no that's not necessarily true uh why is
something being complete good news
okay
so the thing is that if for all we know
it might be the p equals to np i'm still
holding up hope
and if being able to impede that that
means that we have universality right we
can learn the class of all functions we
care about okay now this i mean again
this is like maybe the biggest and most
important consequences to np okay but
that also means that
if we want to get any negative result
about learning we have to you know make
some uh we're gonna have to make some
assumptions at least that piece is not
gonna put np and then there's obviously
okay unfortunately most of you many of
you actually uh thought that it's values
that uh uh it can be complete and that's
you know kind of pure because you know
if
um
uh if p
is not equal to np then that means we
cut likely can't do this over here you
can say well okay
maybe you know p equals to np just tells
me that uh erm is not extractable that
it can't actually there's no
if p is not equal to np there's no
polytime algorithm that finds the small
the that does erm over the class of
program of
uh functions computable in time t
but okay erm is only one way of learning
maybe i can learn using a different way
maybe for example if i train my neural
net that's not exactly rm for short
programs uh maybe that would actually
solve the problem okay so maybe maybe
somebody um
can come up with the you know maybe matu
who's really very smart seriously maybe
you can come up with a uh
uh with a learning rule that does
actually successfully uh uh learn the
class of social programs so it means
that matrix uh came to me and said nothi
i have a learning rule and i can
guarantee to you that this learning rule
uh whenever there's a short program that
gets small error my learning rule will
also output a predictor it's not
necessarily going to do erm over short
programs it's also going to output a
predictor that has error almost as good
as the
uh as a natural uh
let's say short program in short run
time right so whenever there's a program
with small run time to get small air my
learning rule is going to output a
predictor that also has a
small error or almost as good as this
fast program okay
so should i believe matush or not
i know the fact that p is not equal to
np doesn't mean that matrix can do that
right because you know maybe you know of
course he wants this to do to be
efficient right because maybe there's
some other clever programs that are
doing it
but the thing is that um
at least if cryptography exists we have
to make at least one way functions exist
we have to make slightly stronger uh
complexity assumptions at least if i
believe one way functions exist and i do
believe one-way functions exist
unfortunately
then i know that maharish is wrong right
so whenever you see and that's why matu
should never tell me that right but that
means that whenever somebody comes to
you and say you know i have this thing
and it always you know uh
works right then you know that you know
something is wrong here okay
so uh and it's pretty you see this in
some sense you know if we could have
such a thing we could actually invert
any function right because we could get
samples from that function invert it or
another way to say it you know one main
function is this basis of uh
cryptography right so cryptography rests
on the fact that there's things that are
easy to
to uh encrypt but hard to decrypt right
you can that's it it's public key
photographer also like general
cryptography you don't want you know you
want even if you have examples of uh uh
you know plain text and ciphertext you
don't want to be able to learn the
mapping from ciphertext to plaintext
right and if you could do um
uh uh if you there is you could have
universal learning you could break any
crypto system so in some sense okay so
in some sense you know you either have
uh cryptography or you have machine
learning right it's either us or them
and unfortunately
for us i think it's them but uh
okay
um okay so um so what's going on here so
in some sense there's um
uh okay i'm uh see how this uh talk is
gonna go because i'm currently where i
thought it'll be after 15 minutes uh so
um i hope you're at least enjoying this
so um what we said is in some sense
there is a free lunch right so there's
there's no uh there's no free lunch and
i can't learn anything but they can
actually learn anything they care about
but this is of course a cheating free
lunch because i can learn anything i
care about but using a method that's not
implementable okay so
so really what i should ask is what can
i learn using a tractable method and the
real no free launch maybe says is this
you know a complexity theoretic result
it says at least if crypto exists then
there's no efficient method that can
learn any efficiently computable
function okay and so now maybe we have
to revise a bit what we mean by
inductive bias because just saying that
uh
we have an inductive bias and you know
reality is captured well by a small
capacity class
is not really enough because in
particular we said that you know the
class of efficiently computable function
is actually very small really our
inductive bias has to break two barriers
both this computation the statistical no
free launch and the computational
freelance right so if you talk about
inductive biases what is the bias that
allows me to break the free launch
i really need to talk about you know
breaking both of these free lunches
and so really when you have a learning
rule this learning rule in order to work
it cannot work on any reality it has to
learn learning learn under some
assumptions
and these should be both assumptions
that are you know strong enough to break
also this computational barrier right so
now when we talk about inductive advice
it's important to keep both of these in
mind
okay um good so let's go back to feed
forward networks and the
we said feed for networks are in some
sense universal
but the
the problem is of course computation now
we're getting back to uh the second half
of spencer's talk um that um
it's much uh harder to actually you know
implementing erm is very difficult okay
so what i mean in difficult um so
spencer saw it in some very limited
cases right we do have some further
inductive bias we can maybe do here but
in general it's a
uh you know it's a non-convex
optimization problem i mean there's no
and
difficult but also maybe a better way to
say it is just you know non-convex you
can solve maybe non-convex problems um
but uh
uh
maybe uh more significant is to say that
we just don't have any method that
actually works we don't know if any
method it actually uh um uh trains the
neural network
can we actually prove that no method
exists well okay if you want to do erm
then yes it's very easy so this is a
result actually from ivan blum's
phd
that even for a tiny network even for
the simplest possible network
non-trivial network you can think about
with only two hidden units
then uh you can prove that if p is not
equal to np there's no polytime
algorithm that actually solves the erm
and that problem not only solves zerom
but even just decides whether you can
get a zero predictor or not so that that
means that even basically for any
network architecture proving that you
can always do a rerm is is is futile
right if p is not equal to np you cannot
always do erm but then we're back to
this question of okay maybe matosh has a
clever way of learning that's not with
the rf that does something else like for
example
one thing you can think you can suggest
which many people suggest is
maybe if reality is captured well by a
small network and they train a larger
network then it'll work right so now
note that this goes beyond the rm
because now i'm not saying that i can
necessarily do erm on this big network
i'm i'm saying that my um
in order for
that i can learn using a big network
based on a stronger assumption that
reality is explained well by a small
network
but unfortunately we know that even this
is impossible so we have very strong
negative results they tell us that just
the fact that reality is captured by
even a very small simple network and we
do have to go a bit above two
hidden units i mean the the latest and
uh
and greatest depends on exactly which uh
complexity or cryptographic assumptions
you make but they have to have a super
constant number of hidden units
so even if reality is exactly captured
by a
network with you know some say
logarithmically many hidden units
i know that there is no algorithm no
matter what that algorithm does even if
it tries to get a much larger network it
does whatever it is there's no algorithm
that can always output a predictor that
has error you know better than chance it
has non-trivial error okay
so that means that just
the the the assumption that reality is
captured by a very small network is not
enough to break this computational uh um
in mice note that
in some sense i mean we have to work
hard you know we as a community i had
nothing to do with these results we have
to work hard to get uh results that are
for even very very small networks but in
some sense uh to just say that there's
no algorithm that can always learn just
based on the fact that reality is
captured by a
reasonably small neural network then we
already right off the bat know uh
that that's not possible and that's
really because of this generic uh uh uh
approximation result right so in some
sense when somebody tells you you know
you have neural networks oh that's great
this neural network architecture can
represent anything okay that's what
we're saying here can represent anything
we want anything computable efficiently
it sounds like a positive result but
really it's a negative result because we
already know that this
this inductive bias is not enough to
break the computational barrier and so
if being if the network can represent
all of this that necessarily means that
being able to represent you know being
representable this neural network is not
enough to learn so you already know that
we already know that we cannot learn
anything more presentable but neural
networks okay we have to work a bit
harder to show that you can learn
anything representable even with neural
networks a single layer and a super
constant number of uh
of units
okay um so
uh
in um so where does this wait um
uh where does this leave us okay so what
we saw is the neural networks in some
sense are amazing you can learn anything
the only problem is we can actually
finish in a few minutes okay um so where
does this put us really that puts us
you know
in the same place as using short
programs right so short programs also
are universal they can capture anything
you want right and they have small
capacity if i can actually learn you
know
they'd be a excellent learners in fact i
i promise you that learning using your
erm over short programs or sorry with
program length and things is going to be
like you know the best thing you can uh
you're going to beat any learning world
uh unfortunately it's hard uh uh it's
provably difficult in the situation the
neural networks is exactly the same
right they're universal you can earn
anything if if you could implement irm
but unfortunately we probably know you
know subject to a pretty reasonable
complexity assumption that's not
possible okay so both of these seem
the same
but still like how many people here have
successfully trained something
on with the neural net
how many people have uh successfully
trained something using uh erm or srm
and short programs
nobody okay so why is that i mean it
seems they're equivalent okay and the
real thing is that they're not really
equivalent because short programs are
really hard to optimize in practice i
can't even do local search and short
programs right i mean it's like uh um
uh okay so short programs actually are
incomputable but even if i go to like
you know bounded time or something i
can't even do local search right so it
doesn't make sense to take a program and
start like changing characters and
seeing if it's going to improve the
error like what happens if i take a
program and change a character
it's going to crash right it's not going
to do anything right it just is no it's
really difficult to in practice to
search this space whereas deep networks
we do actually have uh uh really good
methods for doing local search so one
thing they're continuous they're
amenable to this local search and it
seems that this local search frequently
succeeds and that's maybe why if we go
back to these uh generic mode of
computations we talk about turing and
tring and shannon with the
circuits and uh uh later from human uh
with the you know
ram programs um
why maybe neural nets which were not
didn't catch on as a model of
computation did catch on for learning
right because really what we want to
learn a generic model of computation
right that can capture anything but
that's amenable to local search right
and neural nets are exactly amount of
computation that's amenable to local
search right that we can just change the
weights a bit and things change a bit
right okay and maybe this is the the
success and so really what happens is
that even though uh um
uh neural nets are are uh you know
provably not learnable we have lots of
empirical success so what's going on
here right why are we succeeding in
training neural networks and this is to
me the big question right so and there
has to be we know that we can't learn
any neural network we have these
negative results so there must be some
kind of magic property okay some kind of
real inductive bias that tells us that
you know under this magic property
actually we can if reality obeys this
magic property then we can actually
train the neural networks using sgd
now i have no idea what this magic
property is the only thing i know at
this magic property is not this magic
property is not being representable by a
small neural net that provably i know is
not sufficient it has to be something
beyond that so that means that if you go
to your favorite vision researcher and
ask them okay why are net why is
learning with neural networks good and
they'll tell you how because they're
mid-level low-level features mid-level
features and high-level features and all
this could be captured in your world by
neural net
what they're telling is completely
irrelevant you're just like it doesn't
tell you anything completely the wrong
answer why because all they're telling
you is about the expressive power i
already know that neural networks have
expressive power but they also know that
just being expressible by neural network
is not sufficient for being learnable
efficiently learnable okay and so there
is some magic property but the magic
property is completely different it has
nothing to do with it okay um and this
is i think the biggest uh uh still and
by far the biggest question about neural
networks but that's not what we're going
to talk about today uh what we're going
to talk about in the second half of uh
the tutorial today um
we're gonna try to revisit again uh
these notions of capacity and expressive
power and how they actually play out uh
in uh in your networks
okay so we'll meet again in
uh
[Applause]
so in the interest of time maybe we
defer questions to the break session and
we meet again in 11 15.